in cars three oh good I'm glad we go  from dildos to cars 3 there's actually a  reason I'm doing this cars 3 ok we're  talking Pixar Disney yeah do they get  upset when you're the voice of the car  and then you of the bus and then you go  out and you start talking about you know  dolphin dildos things like that what  does Pixar do or do they send out a team  decide good luck with that  yeah honestly I just hope that you know  talk the only thing I care about is that  it doesn't screw up my chances to have  my character in karsland right because  it's my life's dream to go to Disneyland  and and like see some teenage boy inside  of me right  [Applause]  you